- Before we go, I have one
more uplifting story to share.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat bright music)
TikTok has turned lots of regular people
into bonafide stars.
And one of the most unexpected
is 79 year old Kenny Jary.
Kenny is a Navy vet
who served during the
Cuban missile crisis.
Kenny has such a big
personality and kind heart.
His neighbor Amanda started the channel,
documenting his everyday life.
Now he's known to his 1.3
million fans as Patriotic Kenny.
So it's no surprise
when Kenny's mobility scooter broke down.
The Tiktok community was quick to help.
- Oh my goodness.
(car engine roaring)
Oh my goodness.
(car engine roaring )
Oh my goodness Amanda.
(old man crying)
- You honking your horn.
- I can't believe that.
Is this right?
- This is all yours.
(audience clapping)
- And that's not all
Kenny's fans raise so much money
over $100,000 in counting actually,
that they're donating dozens of scooters
to other veterans.
Let's get Kenny and his
neighbor Amanda in here.
What's up you all!
(audience cheering)
hello!
well, hello to both of you.
kenny You're looking sharp enough.
So thank you so much for your service.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.
- Well, Amanda,
can you tell us more about
why you started the Tiktok channel?
- Sure. I would love to,
well, you know, Kenny,
he started learning sign language in part,
after we met,
I teach at a deaf school
and my friends and family, Jenny,
his buddy, Jerry are all deaf.
And so he was learning ASL
and I started posting videos
about that journey.
Then the scooter broke down
and I posted a video
and really I just knew that
people in our community loved Kenny
and the world would love
Kenny and I was right.
I just didn't expect it to be that right.
(chuckling)
- You're a hit Kenny.
Well, Kenny, Amanda is
like family to you, right?
- Yes she is.
Yes, we do all kinds of nice fun place.
She sure is.
- I love that.
Well, Kenny
what does it mean that
so many people stepped up to help you?
It seemed like it really affected you.
It was so beautiful
when you found out that scooter was yours.
- Yes, it did.
- What they mean to you?
- What did that mean to me?
That meant the world to me,
you know, it's just so awesome.
When that scooter that I got,
I never thought that
would happen to my life.
Believe me.
- Oh my God. Well,
I couldn't think of a
better person to give it to
you are such a sweetheart
and you're so fun and you're such a light.
Thank you so much Amanda
for sharing these videos.
And thank you Kenny, for joining us.
I'm liking a post right now, right?
(audience clapping)
And that's not all
our season long partner pilot pin.
The go to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
wants to honor ultimate overachievers
just like you.
So they're going to be using
their G2 jelling pen to write.
you a cheque for a $1000.
That's $500 each.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my goodness.
(audience clapping)
- [Show Host] All right
Thank you guys, God glows!